[Music]
hey y'all it's sunday
you still have the you still have the
audio on your thing yeah it's
distracting
it's bright in here
yeah why is it so bright oh i guess
because that door maybe because that
door is open right now it's weird
because like the last couple days um not
that i'm complaining but it's been
raining like the last couple days and it
was actually cold it's still cold today
i think it's only like i think it only
got out up to 61 or something like that
man it was so nice yesterday
that's a little better
yeah that's i didn't really understand
why it was so bright
because right this time of day it's like
oh you're on that stool yeah
yeah so yesterday we finally finally uh
went and saw antlers
and i have to say
kind of a mixed bag
i thought it was yeah i thought it was a
little disappointing
um you know it maybe it was kind of a
thing because i had really been looking
forward to seeing it because it was
supposed to come out like more than a
year ago right and then it kept getting
pushed back
and so i was kind of like man what's
that going to come out man when's that
going to come out and then so i don't
know maybe i was like over hyped and i
didn't read like any reviews of it but
even like i kind of just heard through
the grapevine that some people were like
i did you know it's i didn't hate it
it's just that
because there was some [ __ ] i really
liked about it
um
i you know i really really liked the um
kind of the the look of it like the
atmosphere of it it was like very grim
it had like a really good uh sense of
place it's supposed to be like in this
you know dying town in oregon i think
they shot it in british columbia in
canada
so they they really captured that like
this kind of hopelessness and despair
kind of thing they really had that going
for it uh the monster was super super
cool uh that looks really good
especially like toward the end and the
gore was really good like all the you
know all the people that got attacked by
the monster and like the aftermath like
looked really really disgusting and
awesome
um and all the acting was good and stuff
it just seemed like i think the main
issue was pacing yeah i think that was
kind of the main issue that was kind of
like bothering me and long and drawn out
at the beginning and then
once you see the monster and [ __ ]
there's not much payoff and it's over
pretty quick
there's just problems with it you know
and
jenny kind of disagreed with me at the
time i said it but i'm gonna [ __ ]
reinforce it again you got a monster
that can kill dudes
even [ __ ] up a cop
and then it killed a bear but when this
woman confronts it she doesn't have much
problem with it she just kills it with a
sharp stick
and i'm like
yeah okay
you know so i guess it wasn't that
wasn't that hard to kill then
if a woman can kill it with a sharp
stick it was literally a sharp stick a
spear i think it was yeah yeah
and you just like
so i guess the monster wasn't much of a
threat is that what you're trying to say
you can kill it with a sharp stick
you know just [ __ ] stupid you know
yeah i get yeah i get what you're saying
that was well the problem i i had with
it is that like i said i didn't mind
like the acting was good and everything
like that but i feel like it was too
much
build up like because for the three
first three quarters of the movie like
they kind of showed some monstery stuff
and they showed like some people getting
killed and everything but for the first
three quarters of it it was mostly just
kind of like build up and you know
character development and stuff which
like that's fine but then like once it
gets to like essentially the monster
rampage at the end was it wasn't really
rampage but you know what i mean once
you get to that part it seemed like it
was over like really really quickly like
there wasn't like a really big battle or
anything i kind of feel like too i mean
the monster maybe its threat was more
like because i mean obviously i think
everybody knows this by now it's not
really a spoiler that the monster is a
wendigo but um
but what it is is that i mean because
there's a wendigo and then if you kill
that wendigo then it just passes on to
the next one so it's like essentially
even if you can kill that one there's
like always another one waiting in the
wings i guess because it's like kind of
like a
disease or whatever
you know what i mean
um
yeah joe said i've been waiting ages for
this to come to stream is it available
yet i don't know if it is i mean like
obviously it just started in the
theaters like last week i think so i
don't know if they released it
simultaneously to streaming services or
not because i know they've been doing
that
but
i don't know i kind of like this was
based on a short story which i haven't
read i've read some of nick antoska's
other stuff but he wrote a short story
called the quiet boy
and uh that's what this was based on and
he kind of covered the screenplay i kind
of feel like what they were shooting for
and i think they were partially
successful
they were shooting for
some kind of like quote-unquote elevated
horror where
you know something like the babadook or
hereditary or something like that where
the horror was kind of like partly
symbolic or it could stand for things
you know like the babadook like the
monster was like grief and things like
that and i get that they were trying to
do that that the monster was a real
monster but it was also indicative of
well it could have been indicative of a
lot of things i think that was part of
the problem was that it was a little
muddled they were trying to like the
metaphor
well is the monster trying to be abuse
is the monster trying to be the economic
depression of the town is the monster
yeah so it you know it was an
environmental thing yeah it just seemed
like they were trying to do too many
things at once and i was just kind of
like settle on one metaphor it was it it
was literally when you listen to the
news you listen to the native americans
you listen to it was what it what it was
symbolic for
was the white man desecrating the
[ __ ] nature of the native americans
and
uh mining they should have never been
mining that damn coal that's what it was
but it was so muddied
you don't really get that message unless
you really well
the thing i have is that like you did
get that but they also had but then also
there was like a subplot about abuse
like about um
just giving it a bad review
all right so now it says it's
reconnected okay it says it's
reconnected
says it's reconnected
there it is it's got green people
they're saying it's back it's back okay
yeah
it's back for me
all right and they don't want us [ __ ]
talking bad about this movie man the the
powers that be i'm sure it's not the
powers that be don't talk bad about this
movie no because i was having problems
with it even before we started streaming
sorry i know you think that everything
is experiencing they're trying to get
it's not a conspiracy it's tech it is
tactics tactics are over no it's like
because i i was going red even while we
were still having that before we even
started talking all right it goes right
all the time maybe that ai they might
get the ai
but go ahead jenny the thing is like uh
not that good but like i said he was on
a roll you were you were telling it like
it was well no i don't even like really
remember no i'm just saying that um
you know it's like if you wanted to do
the environmental message that's cool
like you know what i mean there was a
lot of monster movies like that in the
70s and you know that's a totally legit
thing that you could be doing and like i
said i like that they
went mostly full-on with like you know
the native american thing was like a
wendigo rather than just like making the
wind to go monster and not going into
the actual like what it actually does
represent so i like that they did that
but like i said there seemed like
there seemed like too much stuff going
on and like each thing like each
metaphor for whatever the monster was
supposed to be was like underdeveloped
like i said or contradicted by something
else
i mean because for a time they spent a
lot of time on um you know the economic
depression of the town and the abuse
that was going on you know what i mean
like a lot of the parents being like
having lost their jobs and now a lot of
them are like cooking meth and [ __ ] like
that so they went into that a lot and
they went into
you know um carrie russell's character
whose name was julia i think like the
teacher and her brother the cop and how
they had been abused by their father and
how she had been forced to like move
back here like after the father died to
like help take care of the family home
and everything and so i kind of wish
that they had just taken that
you know just the abuse thing and just
kind of concentrate on more on that
instead of trying to
because that was the thing too is that
the little kid
lucas like at the center whose dad turns
into a wendigo essentially is you know
that could have also like tied in with
the whole abuse thing and i feel like
they were trying to do that but then
there was too much other stuff
there was too much other stuff going on
i just felt like it was kind of like
underdeveloped yeah they i think that it
needed more focus
and i think that it needed
some of the stuff like from the
beginning probably could have been
trimmed out and they could have like
prolonged some stuff the final you know
like the final confrontation they could
have like prolonged that instead of the
wendigo just like kicking everyone's ass
pretty much
i mean i really did now i the monster
looked [ __ ] cool and that was not cgi
um so i really appreciate all the
practical effects in this they look
spectacular um particularly the one
where um
after the guy like the wendigo like
busts out of the guy's like skin or
whatever and it's like the husk is left
it's like that looks amazing so like i
said the special effects really good
it's really gross it's really gory and
gnarly and i love that kind of thing um
you know like i said monster design
fantastic the acting is fine i liked the
tone of it i liked the atmosphere of it
it was very creepy and
you know just full of drip with despair
and stuff i just like i said i i kind of
feel like it was mostly just like a
pacing issue and maybe like a focus
issue yeah like they could have they
could have like trimmed some some of the
kind of subplotty stuff out or some of
the other kind of metaphorical elements
out and just focused on one thing
and then
kind of just made it so like when they
were fighting the monster at the end
made it more like epic because it did
kind of feel like the end was just kind
of abrupt yeah i'm gonna attempt to say
it again because it may have been cut
off by the ai the ai gods cut me off
i agree with everything that jenny's
saying
because
there's all the secondary stuff and all
the supporting symbolism they were
trying to do because that failed what it
really came off as is kind of like a
flaccid and yes i said flaccid a flaccid
alien
anybody know what movie that's
where you got a woman trying to save a
child from a [ __ ] big practical mom
yeah
wait no no it came it came back again
i've just i've been there don't like me
i've been having trouble with this kind
of with all my computers yeah whenever
all the computers because that way
that way um
uh
it's just a it's just a story about a
woman saving the [ __ ] kid from an
alien monster about the size of the damn
alien queen
it's a practical effect it's pretty good
but you don't get much of it if you
wanted to see if you want to see this
movie just watch alien 2. it's a lot
better it's that same con it's that same
it's that same concept
it's the same idea yeah like i said
there's there seems to be a kernel of a
good monster movie oh yeah it could have
been much better it's just that because
that monster looks super cool uh i have
to say that monster is cool and i've
always really liked the wendigo
uh mythology yeah uh and they do go into
that in this but i that was another
thing that i don't like like graham
greene is in this like as the token
native american character and that that
explains the when to go to the white
people yeah but that that's like all
he's he's literally in like two scenes
he has like one and i was just like
really you you have graham green who is
he's in a [ __ ] ton of movies he's in a
lot of movies and i really like him and
it's like don't just like don't put him
in your movie and he's like not even a
main character he just shows up and says
this is what the wendigo is like you
guys [ __ ] up
try to drop all that fake high-minded
pretense and all that fake [ __ ]
suspense and just do what alien 2 did
make it a [ __ ] really cool
suspenseful action movie with a bunch of
horror in it and [ __ ] keep the
audience going through the whole [ __ ]
thing and then you got the native
american there he's helping and [ __ ]
then he's fighting it and just you you
just with badass action sequences yeah i
wish i wish he'd been a main character
yeah it just made me sad that they just
kind of like relegated him to the
sidelines i'm like he's like even though
i'm the only native american [ __ ] in
this movie and this is our myth so i'm
the one that knows about the [ __ ] why
you know why can't i get up i just i
think he was literally in like she had
his ass sitting there through the whole
thing basically being bishop he'd been
like bishop from alien too yeah telling
everybody what to do you know don't
worry i don't want to do this but i'm
going to go down this pipe
[Laughter]
the movie was so bad jenny almost beat a
[ __ ] up in the [ __ ] i said james
what no it wasn't because of that she
was gonna come back well it wasn't
because she kept talking
yeah jenny [ __ ] called her out right
in the damn theater and i'm just going
oh [ __ ] i'm gonna have to beat a
motherfucker's ass no it wasn't because
she was with her i thought it was her
boyfriend turned to be her dad that was
her dad yeah that's as i said jenny's
getting me into a fight
[ __ ] but and she came back later but
[ __ ] jenny just blew her off
she she apologized later i thought jay's
gonna beat her ass i'm talking i would
yeah
there is nothing okay that this is gonna
i was gonna say there's nothing i hate
more no there's a lot of things i hate
more but one of the things one thing
that really irritates the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of me is people that go to movie
theaters and talk
especially nowadays i'm like [ __ ] if
you want to talk during a movie stay the
[ __ ] home in your goddamn living room
and watch it i didn't pay to come see
this movie to listen to you [ __ ] jab
your jaws for half of the [ __ ] movie
right so it's like she's over there i
knew they were going to be in like
trouble we got there a little bit early
because we like left early and then we
went to lunch or whatever
and so we went in the theaters we were
there like 20 minutes early or whatever
and i already knew these two were going
to be trouble i didn't know it was
because i wasn't really looking that
closely at them it just looked like old
people but i guess it was like a
middle-aged woman and her dad
and uh so
so they were over there and i could
already tell it was gonna be bad because
they were already talking really loud
like before the movie started which okay
fine the movie's not starting it's cool
um
but usually people that talk that loud
before the movie starts we'll not have
any compunctions about talking loud once
the movie starts and i already heard him
pissing and moaning about how many um
trailers there were and i was like have
you not been to the movies they there's
a lot of trailers like if you're gonna
[ __ ] about it then get here later no i
don't think they've been in the movies
in a long time i guess not but it's just
kind of i'm like well is that a bunch of
lion anyway she lied and told me that it
was like he was a war hero on his
veterans day and he couldn't hear and so
i guess she had to like narrate the
movie from like
are you [ __ ] serious [ __ ]
i didn't say anything but i'm like i'm a
disabled veteran retired [ __ ] veteran
it's not veteran's day yeah i was like
what i'm looking at that dude and i'm
going nah
well that's the thing it's like like i
said i already knew they were going to
be trouble and it's just like the whole
time they were we were in this row we
were like in the middle it was like e
and they were at the end of our row even
though the place was like half empty
like they're already trying to get away
from the damn screen
yeah so they're already over there and
like i said they were loud before the
movie started like just talking and they
were talking to some people behind them
and you know whatever and he like i said
he was bitching about how many trailers
there were oh i hope this is the movie
thank god the movie started i'm just
like dude just shut up and like and then
like the movie starts and all i hear
from over there is fidgeting like cups
going
and then she's like
and then
just like for half the [ __ ] movie
yeah and i'm just like over there going
i'm going to kill these people i think
i'm literally going to get yeah she's
about 50 and he's probably about 70.
yeah and i was just kind of like
i was like look if you're a grown-ass
adult and can't sit still and shut your
[ __ ] face for two hours then you need
to not go out in public ever seriously
or not at least not go to the movies
100 iq grown ass adult is still a child
compared to me even if they're 50 or 70
and that woman got up like four times
like to go to the i'm like do you have
irritable bowel syndrome or something
what is the batter with you i'm amused i
was amused
i was like sit down and be quiet
i thought you were like it's that hard i
thought jenny got me into a fight though
i was so mad i didn't i didn't really
pay attention to this wait and then i
saw the dude later i was like oh all
right yeah i [ __ ] i'd do that they
left yeah they left after i yelled jenny
drove them out yeah
yeah because
because tom whispers to me he's like you
drove him out and i was like good johnny
drove him out yeah they were pissing me
i didn't see him
the whole [ __ ] time all i could hear
over there was just
like the whole like half of the whole
[ __ ] movie and i'm just like would
you guys shut your [ __ ] faces why is
that difficult all right so in um
summation
this this movie had some good [ __ ] in it
i mean it's worth watching like for the
monster and the gore i say no i say it
isn't worth watching
it had it was a good monster it had
some good ideas in it but it was so
badly developed and the way it was
delivered and it was so front loaded
with a bunch of uh
kind of slow suspense scenes that pay
off don't pay off that very well
uh and then it ends up in kind of like
uh kind of like a fake alien 2 type
situation where a woman's going to go
down into the into the alien nest and
save the [ __ ] baby
it's basically what it is uh other weird
[ __ ] happens in it
it doesn't matter though